good evening I'm Denise Valdez a bill to
regulate street food vendors is now a
law here in Nevada Governor Lombardo
signed SB 92 earlier this week changing
the landscape for those who are selling
in neighborhoods and other local areas
Sasha Loftus joins us live tonight with
more on what this all means Sasha
case we've all seen these Street vendors
on bikes or golf carts selling things
or drinks now this new law will simply
regulate them and those behind it say
it's a real benefit for those here in
our community
my parents actually actually used to
sell oranges Mauricio Garcia Lopez
shares how his family used to make ends
meet I know how the feeling of the
accumulation they go through to
day-to-day basis he's one of many happy
to see a bill regulating street food
vendors signed into law this week at the
bottom line I believe that street food
vendors deserve to be treated with
respect and dignity SB 92 which was
sponsored by Democratic senator Fabian
donate allows these vendors to legally
work in neighborhoods and other local
areas while providing them an
opportunity to become legitimate
businesses for a lot of them this is
their American Dream right Tony Ramirez
of make the road Nevada a group that
worked on the proposal calls this a
crucial step forward for those
contributing to our community this
population
uh vendors who are primarily immigrant
primarily Latino and these folks are
just trying to provide for their
families it will also allow local
governments and health districts to
regulate licensing uh they're going to
be able to hold everybody accountable
something Garcia Lopez calls a win for
everyone especially those he says are
working hard to put their own food on
the table they could all go uh wake up
in the mornings and and probably go to
their jobs
[Music]
now the law says these vendors will have
to stay at least 1500 feet away from
Resort Hotels large stadiums or
convention areas they're also supposed
to stay off of the side of the highway
those backing it hope the law will go
into effect sometime in July reporting
live tonight social Loftus 8 News now